hi
so i remember from last lockdown that my
focus was completely shot out of the
roof when lockdown was happening where i
live and now lockdown is happening again
and i already noticed that the last two
weeks i had such trouble focusing so if
you recognize yourself in this
i will give some tips and tricks during
this video of what i have learned the
last week on trying to increase my focus
and productivity
and yeah i hope you learned something so
hi i'm charlotte fraser a phd student in
computational neuroscience in the donors
institute in the netherlands
and this month i want to spend a little
bit on
establishing some healthy habits or
routines that can help me get through
the what is it fourth lockdown i'm not
entirely sure anymore what is time what
is memories
anyways so i want to establish some
healthy habits and routines that can
help me stay focused on my phd and
hopefully stay a little bit productive
so this week i have three things i
really wanted to focus on the first was
deep work the second was establishing
some healthy habits for my body and my
mind and the last one was a little bit
about mindset
so the first thing i focused on was deep
work and that's based on the book by cal
newport called deep work and he really
establishes this difference between deep
work on the one hand and shallow work on
the other hand so deep work in your phd
or during your studies could be
writing up your big projects doing the
coding doing the really important
basic things for your project and
shallow work on the other hand is then
reading emails for example or going to
all these meetings or random lectures
about productivity which i go to a lot
but anyways let's ignore that
so i wanted to establish this week a
little bit more focus on
deep work and call newport gives several
tricks and little habits that you can
establish but i think the most important
thing that he says is to just make time
for deep work so have a block of time
that is solely focused on deep work so
for me that's around four hours i would
say so i usually have this block in the
morning but what i noticed lately is
that i do have a little bit of trouble
on focusing in the morning so i want to
create two blocks or even three blocks
that i could have
for deep work so one is in the morning
one is in the afternoon and one is in
the evening and that's not to say that i
have to do every block
deep work but more to say that i have
three chances in a day to do
deep work and i want to catch one of
them because i notice in myself that
sometimes if i'm not productive in the
morning i really get into this mindset
of the day is lost it doesn't matter
anymore i can just spend the entire day
watching netflix because my morning has
been horrible
but i want to get out of this mindset
and try to
give myself three chances to do deep
work and just try to catch one of them
and i will focus for four hours and then
i think i should be able to manage some
deep work every day the second thing i
really wanted to focus on this week as
well is to create a little bit healthy
habits that i will force myself to do
during the lockdown because i remember
from last lockdown that i stopped
sleeping on time i stopped eating
healthy i ordered in all the time
because i felt so sad for myself and i
also completely stopped exercising so
this year i want to be my own strict mom
that tells me to wake up on time i will
try to
eat at least one healthy cooked meal a
day and then lastly
i will do
at least one hour of exercise outside if
possible
because
i know when the gyms are closing i get
really down just because i cannot move
and i think the gyms are closing
soon so i need to get this habit set
before
everything is going down and the world
is burning again
so yeah hopefully
i will manage that
and the last thing i also wanted to
focus on this week is to remind myself
that it's a marathon and not a sprint
and that's kind of to say that sometimes
when i have a really bad day or an off
day i can beat myself up about it
pretty bad i would say and i really just
want to let it go you know if i have a
bad day to just get over it and
keep on working so this week i also
really try to focus on that mindset
and
i'm not really sure how one can change
their mindset so that's why i'm just
saying it in the camera right now but i
think
i'm reminding myself here and there by
pulling little post-it notes it's a
marathon it's amazing it's a marathon
will remind myself that it's not that
bad if you sometimes
lose a day so yeah these were the three
things that i focused on and i hoped you
got some tips and tricks or at least
some inspiration of what to do
and if you are also struggling with
focus and you probably read a lot of
blogs and things as well
so if you have some tips or tricks for
me for the things you learned i would
love to hear them so put them down in
the comments below and otherwise see you
next week for another focus week
hopefully yes okay
see you bye